I don't know where my tongue belongs
choice I mean I feel like it doesn't
touch any part of my mouth somehow helm
I've never seen letters that do that
I feel like polish ism huh language
right [ __ ] [ __ ]
Tim helm but there's a team that's not
an TD that's an L with a cross through
it Cru Jones nope not gonna get this one
that it's got a good squids groans I got
Rudy odds cucas you George
that's much French here than I thought
what Slovak okay this one looks like it
has more of the made-up letters not made
up their polish that's theirs what do
they sound like well whack lata kick
lock Loic what what suave ik see now
I've learned that the W is really a V
that's something I should have known
from the beginning threshold I just got
thrown when they throw all those
consonants together I'm gonna guess that
the art does not make them and that it's
just our usual wrestle ears about
where's the swap
Joshu I appreciate the use of disease
because we don't use these enough hence
the whole da Silva just stock on voix
don't go away so sure sure
since I survived how does it sound
no puns for over bid gosh this looks
like just something you pulled out of a
bag of Scrabble like you just reach in
and pulled out a bunch of letters and
you're like well I'm s zcz sounded won
that escapes me
but gosh because you did the ghost it's
got its own echo would see now this is a
short one
but I know it's gonna throw me this
looks like this word was tried to be
crossed out like three times this is how
they say lols right this looks fun I'm
just gonna have fun with this one
nerds wadis yeah oh that's my favorite
baba wawa worse versus that one for java
wah-wah-wah-wah what does it repeat
words viola
shava it makes a little more sense now
when you tell me what the symbols do
alright
you won all you want
I like the letters you're bringing into
the game these ones I've never heard of
like that oh I don't know how to
pronounce it yes I'll get there don't be
dead yeah what's that